well i'll do it now i was thinking about
this last week
uh i consider myself a mcluhan knight
mcluhan's great
insight
was that
[Music]
technologies especially forms of media
shape human
perception
not only at the societal level but at
the individual level in other words a
culture which watches television is very
different from a culture which
illuminates manuscripts
he was talking about
electron he was talking about media
print
radio so forth and so on
where i find his ideas useful is to then
view
altered states of consciousness induced
by drugs and plants as
extensions of the definition media
mcluhan's definition of media was it is
an extension of man
certainly drugs
are this and
the bridge between these two domains is
television because television is a form
of media and television is a drug
a drug of very addictive potential and
society shaping
impact
it's hard for people to understand like
when you talk about television as a drug
some people say
at once i think it was in this room
someone said
but if it weren't for television how
would my children learn about nature
they let them in yes
and so then
you know you you have to explain to
people
and and this is not an easy concept
apparently that it isn't the content of
television that's bad you know the 30
murders a minute the idiotic drivel
about sex change operations and all that
it isn't the content that's bad it's the
media itself
is bad so it's not that national
geographic specials and masterpiece
theater are better for you than arsenio
it's that it's exactly the same thing
that the content is irrelevant this was
mcluhan's insight when this is what he
meant when he said the medium is the
message
you know
and television works certain changes on
people that are irrevocable
blood pools in your rear end you stare
you your blood your brain waves fall
into a certain limited range and you
know you're on the nod
and just because there isn't a spike
hanging out of your good right arm
doesn't mean any dimension of moral
righteousness is accessible to you when
you look at other people who abuse
states of mind
and the last thing i want to say about
mcloone because it's the last thing i've
thought in the privacy of my own mind is
people are always saying why did mcluhan
fade so quickly it was thought to be
this incredible breakthrough in the
understanding of culture and media and
what the hell happened the guy
apparently had no disciples and after
any huge initial impact it all
disappeared and i myself have been
puzzled by this and then it struck me
last week as i was driving somewhere
mcluhan's message
was anti-capitalistic
and that's what must have undone him the
establishment was not interested in
hearing that television was heroin
in any interpretation or from any point
of view and so he was just buried as a
crank an incomprehensible canadian
catholic male white nitwit that nobody
should
bother with but i i think the insight
was profound and can be taken further
because
what is really happening as i see it in
the culture wars now
is that
you know mcluhan predicted a great clash
between the television-based culture and
the print-based culture but in a sense
the compression of historical time
made that phase of the culture
uh war pass very very quickly and now
what is happening is it's really a
completely constipated linear mechanical
material print-based money culture
confronting a heavily tattooed
interactive
networked psychedelic
polyamorous youth culture upon which it
depends to keep its computers running
and its database is clear
and and so uh the exacerbation of these
social differences and extremes is
is even more pronounced and accelerated
than i think mcluhan would have expected
at this point why you don't mention uh
gnome chomskay it seems like
amongst other people michael pereini who
continued the attack on the media of
course chopsticks more of a political
how the media is used to you know
pass along that misinformation and to
infinalize people and make the public
incapable of critical thinking and how
the ruling elites are using the media as
a tool for
manipulation and particularly
american the american public
yeah well i think he's doing a great
thing i guess the reason i don't mention
him is i'm very
wary of anyone i don't completely
understand
and when i think of chomsky i think of
transformational grammar
and i went to 10 lectures by him at
berkeley in the late 60s and i was
impressed yes but
enlightened not quite because i couldn't
wrap my mind around what the rap was
he is doing great work gore vidal is
another person whose critique of
american civilization is great
i guess i'm a little different from
these guys because i've never sat down
with noam chomsky but i imagine
that they are ultimately rational
liberals
you know and believe that
somehow
political
um
uh
action
will solve our problems
i'm i have a slightly harder to
understand position
i i don't believe any mistakes have been
made
i think history was a necessary
um phenomenon you know the french have
this expression to step back before you
leap
and i think history all 10 000 years of
it was a gathering of our tools
and an embracing of ourselves for what's
about to happen i also don't think
governments understand or control
the process
that the good news on this planet
is that it's out of control
i mean i never controlled it you never
controlled it so when we say it's out of
control
we mean that it's out of somebody else's
control who really did dream of
controlling it at one point and then
lost control i don't know who they are
the imf the world bank the u.n somebody
out there the communist party they
certainly lost control
and this lack of control
in the evolving process means that it is
not being obstructed by human intent
or political
um
manipulation whatever is happening has a
will of its own i sort of script it all
back into biology i really think that
history is a temporary
um
and unusual circumstance
that even though it lasts let's say 15
000 years it should be thought of as a
very thin membrane
between two very different kinds of
existence
the existence of of uh
technology-less
uh people
uh
living in their myths and their songs
and their stories and their shamanically
created world and
the fusion of of billions of human
beings with their own technological
expressions in a in a planetary and
transplanetary culture and the
transformation is instantaneous
in that amount of time in biology a fly
adds a spur on one hair of the two front
legs that's the speed at which biology
moves and in that period you know we go
from a primate population with a
symbiotic relationship to cattle and
mushrooms on the plains of africa to
some kind of
instrument of the logos that hurls
instruments outside the solar system
downloads all information into databases
reduces the earth informationally to a
point
so forth and so on something
extraordinary
is happening here and we are called upon
as people living in this world to
understand it
and
all our one of the things mcluhan said
that i love is he said we are moving
into the future like people who drive an
automobile using only the rear view
mirror
that's how we're going into the future
we're being guided by marxism
christianity rationalism uh union
psychology yes all these things but my
god none of this is referent to what is
ahead
[Music]
you